payroll tax relief small business is
responsible for employing I think a
majority of the work force and that
would be good if there were some
incentives for loyalty and in some
capacity that way to turreted to um to
uh I can't think of the word but um to
reward employee of employers who are
dedicated to their workforce in some tax
related way it's hard you know I really
care about the people that work for us
we have very little turnover and it's a
labor-intensive you know I'm not doing
keyword arbitrage on the Internet where
I don't need anyone to work for me i'm
doing i'm in the retail business so we
need like a lot of people we need you
know all hands on deck at all the time
so it does it's those are very important
things to us i think it's very important
because you know every every big company
was small at one point so and i think
you need to have forums in places where
people can can cultivate their ideas
without being you know overburdened by
the tax consequences of trying to
execute so i think there should be
liberties given to small business you
know some sort of window you know maybe
relative to the size of the company
where you have some incentive to operate
where you get some sort of rebate you
know we see it in a real estate market
quite often especially in New York City
you know developers are given abatements
to build buildings so eventually they
can raise the tax base and it would be
nice if we had that in small business as
well